العاده الاعلاميه عراقيه شفناها بتقتحم
عالم التمثيل السنه الماضيه في مسلسل وطن
وهذه السنه هي واحده من بطلات دفعه لندن
وحقيقه
كثيرين والتعليقات عليه ماليه المنصات
اهلا فيكي معانا يا رولا طبعا كل عام وانت
بالف خير ومبروك كل هذه الضجه
والشغل اللي عاملينه
وانت بالف خير وشكرا ينعاد عليكم بالخير
والبركه يا رب علينا وعليك طبعا وعلى
الجميع ان شاء الله رولا خليني ابتدي
اتكلم معاكي اول شيء يعني قبل ما ندخل في
موضوع انه الجدل وما الجدل والكلام ده كله
دفعه لندن تحديدا ايش اللي جذبك له
شوفي هو يعني بعد مشاركتي السنه اللي فاتت
بوطن كان دائما عندي اكيد يعني
من ايام
صباح الخير يا عرب برامج
فدائما كنت احب انه لما اعمل شيء لازم
اسوي صح فخلال فتره بعد مشاركه برمضان لا
خليني اشتغل على شي انه خليني اطور نفسي
خليني اعرف الطريقه اللي انا ماشيه فيها
فسبحان الله يعني بدات الامور تيجي لوحدها
ودائما يقول لك هذا تصير لما انت يعني صار
عندك ثقه انه شي حلو راح يصير وصارت قانون
الجذب يعني انجذبتي لهذا المجال
وصار الموضوع
حسب ما سمعت استاذه هبه هي كانت من اول
المرشح
للاسمي اني اكون بهذا العمل طيب يعني رولا
كملت في نفس الوقت العمل عامل مشاهده
كبيره جدا بصراحه يعني في الارقام نحن
عارفين العمل عامل مشاهده ولكن في نفس
الوقت صار فيه هجوم كبير وتحديدا يعني
خلينا من الهجوم طبعا مثلا على الكاتبه
على الفنانين اخرين والكلام ده كله اوكي
خلينا نتكلم تحديدا على الهجوم اللي صار
عليك انت واجهتي هجوم قاسي جدا لاي درجه
ازعجك هذا الهجوم
شوفي هو الهجوم ما كان اول شيء ما كان
بادي بس فردي كان كان عن الخط العراقي ككل
بالبدايه
وهذا الشيء كان كان يعني مزعج لدرجه
طيب هذه اول حلقه يعني طيب خلينا نستنى
خلينا نشوف شو راح يصير بعدين انه شفنا
انه السوشيال ميديا اخدت
مدى بعيد غير ما كان لازم يكون متوقع يعني
اوكي ممكن احنا نعطي راي ممكن وانا احترم
من رايي ان كان سلبي او ايجابي يعني هذا
اكيد وكلنا متفقين عليه لكن انك تعطي راي
او تحكم وتقيم فقط من اول حلقه حسينا انه
هذا شوي كان الموضوع سابق لاوانه هذا اولا
وثاني شيء انه احنا حتى كممثلين او
مشاركين بالعمل ما في حد منا يقبل انه اي
امراه
بعد ما نقول عراقيه او غيرها اي امراه
تتعرض للاساء ثم بالك انك انا عراقيه اقبل
على هذا الشيء
الورق في البدايه ما حسيت انه في اي مشكله
في الشخصيات
كان في اسئله طبعا تعرفي الاستاذه هبه
تكتب بطريقه مختلفه تماما عن باقي
اللايس الدراميه اللي متعودين عليها واللي
نشوفها يعني نحتاج نقرب مره ومرتين وثلاثه
فعلا نفهم هالحبكه وما حسيتي للحظه انه لا
ممكن الموضوع ينفهم غلط انه ليش ليش
العراقيات طالعين في كدور عاملات في عند
مثلا كويتيات
امانه ما كان الموضوع مركز على هذا الجزء
يعني لما تقرا النص ما كان مركز عليه
واصلا احنا لما سالنا الاسئله ولما تكلمنا
مع الاستاذه هبه لما تكلمنا مع الورشه
العامله بالموضوع
توضحت كثير الامور طبعا انا مو حابه احرق
احداث العمل لا بس كل هذه الاشياء اللي
اللي شفتوها كلها راح تتوضح بالحلقات
الجايه انه فعلا
للبنات والكلام هذا كله
تمام مع انه ساره في بدايه الحلقه وهذا
الشيء اللي احنا نعيده ونكررها وسبق وكثير
من زملائي ومن من كادر العمل انه كان في
يعني
سبب ليش اطفال في سن معين لقوا نفسهم في
لندن في شخص خان الامانه ما ذكرنا اي شيء
الها علاقه باي شخص او اي يعني اي شيء كان
واضح
يعني العراقيين العراقيين قالوا انه
رولاكا عراقيه كان لازم ترفض هذا الدور
شوفي احنا قاعدين نتكلم يعني شو سبب رفض
الدور يعني انتم حكمتوا على
شي من اول حلقه طيب انا لو انا شفت في شيء
سيء او في شيء سيء لالي كممثله
اوك كعراقيه هل من المنطق والناس تعرفني
من زمان هل من المنطقه اني انا اقبل شي
يضرني ويضر اسمي ويضر مشواري ويضر الناس
كيف تعرفني فلهذا السبب قلنا من اول يوم
ومن حتى قبل نزل من مسلسل اتذكر اول لقاء
عملناه هذا العمل يحتاج التاني والصبر
وفعلا الحب كان موجوده فيه مفاجات
التهديد يا رولا
لا الحمد لله لا شوفي يعني احنا يعني
الموضوع يمثل المراه او يمس حد
شوي تطلع هذه المشاعر زادت على زوم احنا
كلنا متفاهمين هذا الشيء بس لهذا السبب
نقول يعني صبروا علينا شويه والله العظيم
يعني
مثل ما كان في تفاعل ساره شوي كان قاسي
نوعا ما بس صدقيني بجد هذا التفاعل كان في
تفاعل جدا رائع وتوصلنا احيانا اشياء جدا
جميله بس بنفس الوقت حابين انه الكل يتفهم
القصه يعني على العموم انتم مع الجدل هذا
انتم متصدرين المشاهده يعني ما في جدال في
هذا الموضوع يعني فعلى العموم نحن طبعا
بنتمنى لك التوفيق وزي ما قلتي حنستمر في
المتابعه وحنشوف رولا كل التوفيق لك صراحه
في كل اعمالك القادمه انت جميله عزيزه
يعني واكيد بنتمنى لك التوفيق ونشوفك ان
شاء الله لما ترجع على دبي كانت معنا
الممثله رولا عادل شكرا لك